[Music]
Jessica's a girl that you take to the
party and then you don't see her for the
rest of the night never she's gone and
they're always way too loud or they're
really like forceful in conversation
essica loses her phone every time she
goes out every time so annoying
hang on to your phone Ashley I think
Ashley's a club yes you're meeting
Ashley like the the club something
called like essence or fire Kelly has
jägerbomb in her blood totally makes you
feel bad for not going to happy hours
you don't get off work until 7:00 happy
hour ends at 7:00 she still want you to
go Krister drunk - yeah they drink a lot
like like what's up with Kristen Kristen
go out on a limb here I'm gonna say that
every single Kristen in the world loves
the Hunger Games I feel like every
Kristen would die first in the Hunger
Games
Stephanie's still into like really into
books she's in her third year in medical
school she's like studying her ass off
Stephanie teaches at an elementary
school in Michigan she loves it she's
good at Stephanie's the Stephanie's are
always pretty funny yeah yes the smart
articulate I went to church camp with
Hannah like Hannah has nice books though
she just got good taste in the
literature
I feel like Jamie's a pretty on point
the treasure on the student council
she's very responsible she worked very
hard in school
Hank Elizabeth is Regal she either has a
crown or she she is about to steal one
to only be called Elizabeth if you were
the queen of England I don't know if
Elizabeth or that classy because I know
most variations on Elizabeth they're
like the opposite of classy like
Lizzie's are really cool these are down
Melissa and I bet and Lizzie's can
[ __ ] just date a man is just really
trustworthy if you want to confide in
them but if there's one girl you have a
platonic friendship with it's Amanda hey
these are like an older sister Katie is
always the cool one in the group and
like invites you and makes you dinner
you know mine Katie needs to be sort of
voluptuous and Katie's are blessed
Marissa so red reckless Marissa is a
reckless they're hot they're dangerous
red flag my theory is that any girl's
name who starts with a V
secretly evil Vanessa Victoria Valerie
Vivian Vivian seemed to be nice they
have the capability I'm doing evil thing
her name is Rachel I assume she has a
good punch I feel like Rachel's are
fighters if I had to build an army and
all the girls had one name I would build
an army of Rachel's commercial is ready
to go and yes like hang out with the
dudes the Shalaby like that first girl
who's like a shot of whiskey you're
taken back because it's new yeah Malika
owns a pitbull yeah Malika owns a
pitbull and talks a lot but she's cool
Sarah's with an H they're like you know
your sister with an A it's beautiful
yeah they get that I think Danielle's
are beautiful and they always date down
ten yells you can do best Tiffany's and
Kimberly's are probably just milfs now
yeah all of them Lauren has great dirty
blonde hair that is just like phenomenal
looking and smelling I'm still stuck on
the Princess Jasmine thing so any
jasmine to me is gonna be hot as hell
Eva Eva Eva and Eva good good and that's
a good butt name Havens kind of sexy you
know what hey that I do know it unless
she's gonna be very happy Isabella just
a beautiful woman Madison oh I like that
I like Madison a lot like strong yet
sweet Addison I feel like they're
genteel you don't really know much about
her but she's chill yeah Addison Addison
where you at girl let's yeah Madison
what's up give us a call Madison I'm
picturing dark beautiful skin with a big
nice natural for a whole egg she's right
weaknesses great times man kind of make
you do things
[Music]